it was a great weekend definitely
something many businesses are saying
after the 80 percent
increase capacity went into effect on
saturday
and while increased capacity is
welcoming filling jobs to keep up with
the demand
that's proving to be challenging sally
harramio is live near tropicana and
eastern at a restaurant
hoping to fill jobs as it also plans for
a big holiday this week and that's cinco
de mayo sally
that's right denise i'm at ellie's
restaurant and i visited
many restaurants here in the valley
today owners
are glad for the increased capacity but
also need to increase their workforce
may actually last year we almost closed
down again after we reopened but the
pandemic was affecting us a lot
alvaro cortes owns ellie's breakfast
restaurant and burgers they have been
working hard to keep the doors
open right now we have a lot of specials
you know to try and bring people in from
serving american omelets to mexican
menudo and possole
every day of the week they have a
special very good news for us
we noticed that yesterday and saturday a
lot of more people coming in
so i'm so happy but to keep making his
diners come back
he needs more cooks and that is hard to
find
havana grill owner sergio perez is also
looking to hire bartenders
and a hostess especially after seeing
patrons return this weekend
oh it's fantastic when the people is
coming about about crazy because the
people miss the place
it's full it's very very busy the bakery
the restaurant
the bar everything is full perez says
revenue
increased by 50 percent and expects
cinco de mayo and mother's day
to bring in more business i had the
margarita two for one and appetizer two
for one two we're gonna
have a special for mother's day we're
gonna offer free crepes for
all the mothers we're trying to get him
ready we're hiring a lot more people
so doors are open
i'll care live also looking to hire
lindo michoacan they tell me they're
looking to hire for all positions
reporting live
salihara live local now